[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
I wanted to do something a little bit
different I've been talking a lot about
symbolism obviously since we started all
this but um one of the things I've
mentioned over and over since we started
is this notion that post-modernism can
be turned back on its feet let's say
I've mentioned that Jacques Derrida for
example who's a thinker that everybody
has heard about related to
post-modernism and how his ideas if you
push them in a certain manner they
actually come back right-side up and so
I've seen quite a few comments of people
thinking that is an interesting idea but
obviously I haven't really explained how
it's done what I have been doing from
the beginning is that I've actually been
doing that without explaining what it is
that I'm doing and so hopefully in this
little video I can explain how I try to
do that maybe how it's done so hopefully
all of you can use some strategies to
that say push post-modernism into post
post-modernism I guess we could call it
or just basically a normal world okay so
I'm going to use one particular example
and the example I'm going to use is one
which if you have been following my
videos you will have seen countless
examples of me talking about that
subject in general and so hopefully
you'll also be able to pull in threads
from the other videos that you've seen
so you can totally see how this works
the the example I'm going to use is the
example of hospitality the notion of the
monster let's say so dr. heeda one of
his positions one of the the structure
that he's put about is this notion of
hospitality and his notion of
hospitality can be put in parallel can
be made analogous to other of his
structures another of his structures is
this notion of eschatology for those who
don't know what eschatology is so
eschatology is this waiting for the end
things and so usually it's framed in
Christian terms of this idea of of
waiting and kind of calling upon the
returning Christ and so Jacques Derrida
goes into this notion of eschatology at
the end of Revelations
there is a verse which says come Lord
Jesus right come this this call to to
Christ to return and so what Jack did he
that does is he talks about I'm going to
use it translate these words for myself
because I don't know I've read dated on
French so I'm not sure what what the
English versions are but he has this
notion of an open eschatology and so
this idea of open eschatology has in a
way to do with this idea of hospitality
or you could call it radical hospitality
and what it is in layman's terms it's
when it's what it is when you hear
people say things like you should be
open we should be open we've heard that
all the time right well you're not very
open you have to be open so this notion
of a radical openness and this radical
openness is in a way a an openness which
is so open that it doesn't judge right
so the hadass sees it in a way as the
position we need to have towards the
future right if we want to take we want
to stand and and look out into the
future and then call upon whatever is
going to come and in his in his mind
that is how we always act we we stand
and we look towards the future and we
kind of call for the future to come and
then as the future is kind of man if
itself in order to to be how we have to
be hospitable to the surprise of the
future so that the future can then kind
of manifest itself and and and let say
integrate into the world okay butthis is
really this kind of really has this kind
of radical openness which is that you
you know it's almost this nameless this
idea of almost not naming the future
nots not giving it any name so that as
it comes towards you it it comes towards
you in the most in the fullest way
possible let's say and so there's value
in that there's value in this idea of
eschatology in a way this there's a
value in understanding this position of
eschatology as one of the manners in
which we engage with the world this this
and and there is also there's a certain
positive aspect to that it actually
resembles something that Jordan Peterson
talks about this idea of facing the
future right of being of coming to the
edge of being let's say and then looking
out into adventure looking out into the
future and being willing to accept the
surprise of whatever is going to present
itself to you whatever the hell I would
always always obviously not use the word
present but whatever is going to you
know come in to come into contact with
you okay so that's the basic idea of
hospitality and you can see how this
plays itself out in a lot of things it
plays itself out in in a way in terms of
progress in general people who have this
notion of progress if you ask them to
towards what are you progressing usually
they can't really totally answer because
in a way it's it's kind of progress
without Telos this progress without
purpose but still this notion that we
always need to to to advance and
progress towards who knows
exactly what and so we need to be open
towards these towards what the world is
going to be like in the future of course
there's often an insidious part of that
where people in the back of their mind
they know what it is they want the
future to be but um let's leave that
aside for a moment and so we can also
see it in terms of this notion that we
have to be open towards other people's
ideas open you know this kind of total
openness to other religions to other
cultures to other you know it's like
this this this this idea that we all
need to be very very open right and and
you can pull out all the cultural
ramifications of this idea which wasn't
born just in da-da-da-da-da formulated
it in a way that is it is quite good and
so the idea that I'm trying to propose
or how to then turn data against himself
let's say or let's say bring Derrida so
that he kind of flips back up on his
feet is to continue the process of
deconstruction you would say one of the
the basic tenets of deconstruction is
that you can't totally you can't totally
control the meaning of the text because
the text is always referring outside of
itself it's always referring to other
things the word outside is also a word
the devil won't use but it's always
referring to other things and you can't
totally control what it's referring to
you know either historically or in terms
of analogy or in terms of of of being
referencing other texts it's like you
have so the meaning is always kind of
shifting and sliding because you can't
totally contain it and one of the things
that data dot will do is he'll try to
show how even words reference to other
words and how analogies reference to
other analogies and then he'll try to to
use that to kind of break break apart
the total solidity of the text okay
and so what you what you can do is you
continue that process you you you you
continue it and I'll show you what
happens so in the context of hospitality
and in the context of radical
hospitality one of the figures that
there are two figures that day that dick
atha uses well there's several but two
of them one of them is this notion of
product of a prostitute and so his idea
his he talks about the prostitute as
being this image of radical hospitality
right so the prostitute does not
discriminate let's say on on who on who
she encounters and who she joins herself
with but he's completely open towards
towards whoever presents himself to her
um and so another another image that he
uses is the image of Elijah because in
Jewish tradition there's this notion
that you leave a place open at the table
for Elijah and so it is this kind of
leaving an open space right leaving an
open space for for the stranger Elijah
is the his his name is the stranger
leaving this open place for the stranger
this open place for the future this open
place for you know this this whatever
surprise can present itself to you and
so those are kind of two images that he
uses to to talk about radical
hospitality arrived radical hospitality
now if we look at the prostitute for
example we can see that we can find
stories especially if we're looking
within the Jewish context within the
biblical context there are stories which
talk about prostitution and we and in
fact they actually do fit in this idea
of radical hospitality the example that
you can use is the example of
the two spies in the story of the taking
of the city of Jericho so in that story
the Israelites sent two spies into the
city of Jericho and those two spies are
taken in by a prostitute who lives in
the wall of the city okay
and so the prostitute hides the two
spies and she makes an allegiance with
them and the allegiance is when the
Israelites come to destroy the city then
that they will not harm her and so here
we actually see an example of radical
hospitality where the prostitute is
willing to be hospitable and to be open
to the enemies of the city to those
whose purpose is actually to undermine
and to destroy the city and what's
interesting in this version of the story
is that it's it's actually it's not seen
as bad in this story it's actually she's
she's seen as the as the the good person
as the as one of the heroes in the story
because it is the story is seen from the
point of view of the Israelites and so
the Israelites use the radical
hospitality of the of the prostitute in
order to to to send spies so that they
can infiltrate the city and ultimately
leading towards the destruction of
Jericho okay and so what happens and so
this is now where the where
post-modernism flips back on its feet
because as you disperse the
interpretations right as you let's say
as you let the as you let the story
slide and reference out to other places
and you you bring in other stories which
relate to what you're talking about
which is the
notion of the prostitute and radical
hospitality what happens is certain
interpretations will will pop out and
for example the type of interpretation
which leads to the complete destruction
of your city the complete destruction of
your identity or your your yourself is
one which will stand out and and so
although maybe maybe jacques de that
will will want to continue it too will
want the the thing to continue to slip
and slide it it's at some oast people
that say normal people people who who
have care for for their life for their
city for their family for all those
things are going to notice that you need
to take into account that possibility
within all the other possibilities so
within the radical hospitality one of
the the possibilities you need to take
into is the possibility of the spy who
will come into your city and then
through their actions will destroy
everything you care about now that
doesn't mean that that's what's going to
happen of course not but because of that
possibility all of a sudden what happens
is a hierarchy sets itself up again a
new hierarchy will manifest itself where
that possibility of let's say your city
and your country being destroyed is
going to come to the the is going not
necessarily come to the top in the sense
that that's all that's how you're going
to act but it will come to the top in
the sense that that is the one that you
will be attentive to and that you'll be
careful about and so in that hierarchy
then
there will still be the normal
hospitality towards the stranger the
normal hospitality towards towards
towards other people because that brings
a lot of advantages there are a lot of
advantages which come from hospitality
the you know trade and enriching
yourself you know becoming you know
increasing your your own knowledge your
own understanding of the world all that
comes from this openness towards the
future this openness towards the the the
stranger you know this kind of radical
hospitality that day that talks about
there's a lot of positive stuff coming
from it but there is that one
possibility which is for example that we
will create an AI which will destroy us
or that we will create a more weapons of
mass destructions that will devour us
and so we can't in the end be completely
open towards the future because of that
hierarchy which resets itself up as you
look at how how things slip and slide
the other example of course is the
example that he uses is this example of
Elijah and so Elijah is the stranger in
certain guises that is that is that he
hinder in Jewish tradition and also even
actually in Christian tradition there's
this notion that Elijah comes before the
Messiah that he lied to manifest itself
before the Messiah in in the Christian
tradition we say that the Elijah who
manifested himself before the Messiah
was with Saint John the Baptist's in
John the forerunner whereas in Jewish
tradition they still have this notion
that that Elijah precedes the the
Messiah well if you look at the story of
Elijah then you can also see exactly the
same problem as the story of the
prostitute and the notion of radical
hospitality because in the story of
Elijah the king
is has so much hot openness is so open
to to to other possibilities that he
marries a foreign Queen this foreign
Queen brings in her foreign gods her
foreign ideas and what happens is the
world flips back flips upside down where
the normal traditions of that society
the temple the priests the priests of
the the God of Israel are marginalized
you know they I've talked about this
before in other videos they they
actually become there have to hide in a
cave and so Elijah comes and he he
actually participates in flipping that
back where at the end of the story of of
Elijah and of that that line the the
Queen Jezebel the this this Queen which
brought in all the foreign gods gets
thrown off the wall gets eaten by dogs
and so there is this this this whole
imagery of the the the the foreign queen
finally exiting the the city you know
and and the city kind of fault-finding
it's at least a glimpse of the
possibility of the city finding its
integrity once again as this this this
queen gets ejected from the city and so
once again here's another example of how
if if in the tradition of Elijah there
is this notion of hospitality in the
sense that Elijah also prepares us for
the coming of the Messiah
right there is this really
eschatological aspect of Elijah in the
story of Elijah there is also another
aspect which is the decrying of of the
of the the of the let's say the de
foreign gods and this this idea of of a
world where the normal the normal
tradition of that world is being flipped
upside down and being put into the
margin and so hopefully that will give
you a all of you a little idea of how it
is the
um post-modernism can be brought back
let's say as you let it slip in slide um
I would suggest that you that some of
you look at this I don't know if you've
heard of a real peer review you see that
on Twitter it's really worth following
that Twitter account because in those
tweets is really presented the extreme
of post-modernism some of the the most
extreme statements of post-modernism and
in those statements you can see how
things are already starting to flip back
you know and it's happening in a very
strange way I would suggest that you pay
attention to that if you're interested
maybe I'll make a video on some of those
tweets and you'll let you'll be able to
see it another very even more another
far more banal example but I think one
that's worth watching is that for
example a a traditional position this is
really very kind of basic and and almost
unimportant but it's a good example to
kind of understand how this is possible
you know a just a normal traditional
vision of let's say between of the
relationship between the men men and
women is that the masked men are are are
stronger men are more physical let's say
in terms of strength and and mostly
strength let's say and it doesn't mean
that women cannot be athletic they can't
be strong they can't be fast and there
are many women who are stronger than men
but on the whole in general men are
stronger than women and that's why we've
always had set we've separated the sexes
in sports right so you have men's you
know men's hockey teams and women's
hockey teams men's basketball teams
women's basketball teams right so now
the radical position of the the
postmodernist is that gender is over
gender is a construct gender slips and
slides there's no stability in gender
there are these in between categories
which deconstruct the categories
themselves and infect the category so
that you can no longer have stability in
the categories right and so then what do
you do
we're a gender just kind of dissolves we
doesn't dissolve but it slips and you
can't completely contain it and so then
the final solution to that would be to
stop separating the genders and we hear
we hear constant calls to do that for
example that we shouldn't have men in
women's bathrooms or that you know
anybody can go into whatever bathroom
they want and and I've said this before
the question of the bathroom is very
important it's very important because
when we talk about the bathroom the idea
of of where it is that you evacuate and
you you make yourself whole again you
kind of remove from yourself those
things that are not you it's very
important it is I know people think it's
kind of silly and it is silly but it's
very basic because it's a it's a going
to the bathroom it's something everybody
does and it's something everybody does
which very unconsciously reminds us of
what it is that is not us and what it is
that is us and so the bathroom is very
much linked to identity in a very basic
way okay um that's one of the the ideas
of you know letting anybody go to
whatever bathroom they want okay
well you know the final solution to that
is to eliminate the the the differences
between genders now my son my son is
really into parkour which is this
freerunning you know these these guys
who run around and they jump and they
they hang on buildings and everything
and there's a show on Netflix called
Beastmaster and this show is basically
an obstacle course so my son he really
wanted us to what he really wanted me to
watch that with him and so we watched
the the season of Beastmaster and these
people that are doing all these obstacle
courses and it
pretty good it was pretty good I was
pretty it was pretty interesting um but
one of the things they did in
Beastmaster which is really interesting
is that they let everybody compete
everybody compete together and so they
made no differences between men and
women and then what happened obviously
you know to anybody who has some sense
is that in the end the women never made
it past a certain level they never made
it past a certain level and at the end
it was always men who won the the you
know that every episode had a champion
it was always men and at the end
obviously it was a man who was the
champion and then when you watch that
what you end up thinking is ah I wish
they would have separated the gender
like I wish they would have had a
competition between women and a
competition between men so that we could
see the women that shine and we could
see them and that shine but now when we
do that all we see are the men that end
up shining in this competition and so it
sets up once again a hierarchy it
happens on its own once you level
everything once you destroy everything
the the hierarchy sets itself up on its
own Jordan Peterson has talked about
this before in Scandinavian countries
where in fact if you that where they
have worked very hard at destroying the
differences between men and women what
happened is the difference between men
and women actually maximizes when that
happens and so that is a way pushing
post-modernism to its limit pushing it
to its edge is a way for it to then flip
back on itself and then a normal
hierarchy gets reestablished
so those were just a few example but I'm
sure a lot of you can think of other
ways and other ideas of how that can
happen and so I encourage you all to
write it down in the comments and give
me your ideas about that and so yap so
that was just a quick video I thought
that you
that you guys would enjoy it and I've
got Black Panther coming Black Panther
video coming very soon and so all right
I'll talk to you soon if you enjoyed
this content and our exploration of
symbolism get involved I love to read
your comments in the comments section
below please go ahead and share this on
social media to all your friends and
also please consider supporting us
financially on patreon you'll find the
link to the patreon page in the
description below